[music]
So
what
[music]
So
last round of sinful cup extra
st louis raised to the top step
pedestal of three participants at once
Aronian hungry complications outplayed
for pike magnus carlsson protracted
Endgame Confused Hikaru Nakamura 3
become winners but destiny 4
trips to the final tournament in london
solved the crown of the forests find out right now
[music]
sen fil cup ended and it seemed
it would be time to say goodbye
but no today just a few
minutes will start here we saw fabiano
caruana walks start tie-break
no cup sinful to start the tie-break
reminder for those who are confused
hello dear friends good evening
again for you studios for those who
confused tie-break for winning the cup
sen hele yes it won't be yesterday since the evening
This topic has been actively discussed everywhere in
in general, it can be discussed clearly that
there are people satisfied with the final decision of
people are dissatisfied with the outcome of the decision, but in
the whole situation in which three
everything is great for a chess player
first first prize seems to me more
logical than the situation when one of
they are unhooked by means of slips
again, we can say that
probably spent those breaks could
be low conceived think oh oh oh
most likely sooner or later
happen eat as is and we have
another tie-break and so on for the fourth
a ticket to london will play in from the woods and
fabiano caruana just us ready
as far as I understand show the format before
format
victories is actually my transfer of eggs from
terribly dissatisfied since yesterday
evening I have problems with the translation
but let's try to tell first
created for a game of rapid chess 25
delay of 10 seconds actually here
strange letters for this, it's not a C grade
letter z delay up to delay 10 seconds
in fact, like everything that happened in
st louis in august since im plays
week 1 blitz and then it becomes
more interesting if 11 two draws or exchange
by victories, two games are played in
blitz control 5 plus delay three
seconds
if not two games in blitz like in
poverty is played another such match and
if he's not someone else's one such boy
and that maximum 3 micro matches in two
lots with control 5 plus 3
well, and then in general
such a strange, well, such a brush creature
sand that I want to describe in general
describe
like that, here are the organizers and the judges
in general, everyone involved in this
process hand they're looking for some new
lulz because after yesterday
announce that we will meet again and
we will discuss in the process what to do
then this is of course unexpected for me
solution but nevertheless here we are
We suspect that sooner or later
all the same armageddon but will it be right away
after six games of blitz or more
some to the floor or and they will
continue Pomeranian weekdays
minute because they just can't
continue to play chess
Fisher Lyapaev
on these very my beauty by 2 gods yet
someone doesn't look well for some reason to me
it seems that it will not come to this although oh
the same thing I said about only one 1 3
with the same national
happened to many times already caught here
on the fact that we predicted things
totally wrong and yes
actually there was a draw for colors
on my screen i see that fabiana 1
plays miracles starts with black and then it is necessary
say again
about the history of their personal meetings there is no new
wait they say what you need
see what people are playing for
this is also the position in the grrange from the tour with
this is how it ended it seemed
would gram frequent yesterday but as it shows
that's what we're still on the air for now
didn't even end at all nakamura wounded
And
and Maxim entered La Count already selected in
London and them
occupy first although not 1 5 first three
prize places exactly in fact Fabiana
earned
a little more maxima a little more maxima
yes but that's exactly 26 points hiding in
with the fox so they play this one
today's match for the last places in
final tournament 4 in london which
will pass through
knockout system, yes, it's a little strange that
karyakin in the final table is lower
mamedyarov although he seems to have more
points on but it's the little things before
the general feeling of the looking glass does not leave in
overall in the last couple of days
Fabio also smiles whatever
smiling fabi wanted to add more oh well
here is the last column about prize money if
think that this match apart from everything
it is clear that I would like to play strong
final tournament and so on it's on
just in case match for at least 40
thousand dollars there is the last peep
last prize in london or at
additional 40 thousand dollars because
what they have already earned yes so how
minimum 40000
will play water in these rapid chess for
one day but if and their considerable money
but understandable prestige because
who are not in London will be very
he has an interesting composition, but you saw it on
screen what nakamura
was and dropping wounding is good company
good company and clear what you want in
we can play in this tournament
show while there is still time
london until as soon as i mentioned the prizes in
london let's see let's see
let's see what it looks like
actually there are no more
pure crustaceans clearly need first place
this will actually be the winner.
granfest city and that's interesting
my third fourth are played
not always played, but in general it is possible
welcome as we
we will see more sharat performed very
strong chess players here, as I understand it, are not
divide is impossible to convey here simply
won't come out to share pressed her ladies but also
again today we have only two
person in the arena and probably need to
for a moment to talk about how
looks like they personally have important meetings yes
and there is a rather curious situation again
same not on fragment will show graphics on i
I will start to say in general that Fabian of
goes 42 to classic but at the same time to rapida
and blitz that still has more
relation to what we are going to watch
today there catastrophically came out if
leads with a huge advantage almost
14:04 with some number of draw times
I'll look again for some reason it seems to me
a result of accumulate and more than draws
until 14 49 them show no draws
tells us the all-seeing eye
Yes, I will wash us at some point
show well probably probably show for
fast almost 40 with two draws
well, and accordingly remains
remains 8 until there 10 10 4 0 appears
after in the club jacket of the st louis club
actually yes
fabi in such as to say uni form
rapid chess player since Egor
uhov yes yes the less control so
the shorter the arm, the shorter the arm from half a minute
need a T-shirt
well, you have to take it somehow
some before
no categorical solutions
not bad yes such a mood in one and
another there fabia smiled in a dream like
how good-natured long ago with
one side is so short
match for very big money with another
side but these are extremely professionals
extremely high standard for them I think that
bets don't pressure them
strongly kush does not press therefore
just extra
exercise, and maybe a little
to say about the format as we are all
we will comment yes probably for sure
we will try as well as in the classics
show on the board
different options and so on and so on
blitz maybe we will leave already in sight
off camera from some point
most likely it will be necessary to show near
precisely the maximum increase
cameras and try to keep track of what
happens on the board because
show something at the same time
demo
at that speed it will be impossible
according to the organizers about an hour should
take each game of rapid chess
are they going to do half an hour drank
they will do and that's what I know for sure
don't either mean the second batch of fast
will start either at 2 or 10 minutes
after the end of the first, that is, no more
ten minutes break between the first
will tell us that a person
which is just on your screen
made the first move
head man house of with tons tons
the company that makes these
chess sets and boards and here it is
honored today
make the first code in this tie-break on
the sets are really very nice
for the game I've been playing for the past couple of years
these boards are a pleasure to hold
hands you figure yes and again here
sign sol and caruana sign
so to speak, a certificate about what exactly
they played this tie-break nda not
understand on this but specific collection
these boards are dressed up as far as I understand
every year after the end of the tournament
sold on will bring down at auctions
also for good for good deeds and well
well it but now the man has already planned
to 2 to 4 but in if not in a hurry in if
hands it
smiles and it’s not clear yes, that is, it will go
did you still decide not to change yesterday in
classics actually played party juice
Ivanov who was so strange
Russian in which where they were changed
seventh move and in general if not not
gave the impression of a man who
straight wanted
do not leave a living place on the virtual
Fabian's repertoire and Fabian himself but
how is it today
when the situation compels him even more, and
we'll have to go and then we'll even
somehow scolded because it looked like
he doesn’t catch up with Fabian in any way, yes, yes
it seemed that you needed some for
work there own but also there
us basically like chief and tides there
yesterday was on hikaru nakamura who well
adopted a series of let's say not mandatory
decisions that led to the defeat or
data expression with iran blow in
endgame which people in general like
to say it is not unreasonable
perfectly safe from the start so well
that played out to the ticket and fabi here I am not
I honestly remember dirt for him to do this
earlier even pity early dc-4 horse c6
yeah i cant argue
against against if in principle so to me
seems to have walked quite a lot and
relatively recently, maybe
maybe I merges and in if so
with black played to the interests of 4 step then
that it seems to me that you are up to 2 here
candy 5 5 is absolutely central
the theory of this option is up to say the servants
a regular cable of 4 there are all sorts
different codes short then north i
Erase the old theory, which already seems to be
considered incorrect yes can't can't
say why but missing phase 3 before
from red practice then now I can
roughly imagine what
the next five moves are made by the sides but
why is it suddenly considered not
good for whites is not a question for me
Yes, I think castling is played somewhere
queen b5 there
but milked to win back this pawn on d4 there
some lines that start with
it also turns out the tapolca which they
everyone is actively discussing short short
understood and
what black can move to the knight
three highlights wait after short
castling not sure what if black
play short in the same place from 3 probably already
Well, yes, there is some kind of finger in which
white move horses move after that all
equally capture on c4 with the queen through the squares
would friday 4 answer what black comes out
elephant for 60 thousand can not order
veneration do not restore parades
moves in the head will show us on occasion
how it turns out then it will be possible not
underdoing
yes, and with such statistics
devastating to fast blitz like
it seems that with a favorite of course of the two
separately taken partner, let's say and
also a little longer control over
compared with conventional fast not up to
which 15 plus 10 we are accustomed to this
grunge history plays 2510
well, yes, that is, it is clear that some
far-reaching draw conclusions from that account
and which they currently have
it would probably be a mistake for a short
fabio finds fret b8
let's start can show some
doctor options can actually here
and it turns out vodka nuclear sinku no they
3 short castling of White offers b5
because they can't drink
start 4 teeth 5 that they walk on 6 406
whatever 525 first again ferber to 5 and
to take on any and almost can’t
anyone to acquaint on whom the trouble is katya 24 and
this position is actually pretty
nichols is venomous for what at least
I had the feeling that black and
they call far from every time well
so far even horse 3 few on here is played
in this eating 3 on our screen we
that is, apparently fabi has prepared something
here for a year and again I'm trying
think no, that's just the mouth
adjustments that are, it seems to me
some other options in which black
let's take a double take and there are 6 of us
be life were lydia kind what is but
tapa I'm not sure what it is in this position
in prison could 83
but anyway short 5 slide
on the board as a whole, I would say that it is very
suitable if the style of malt is
game if obtained from this meme steeple
yes with taking 24 stylistically pretty
well, but at the same time, the spiers are very very
specific therefore again talking about
that
that is, there questions of style may not
arise because up to may be
Fabiana just all at home is learned that
called to give Rodionov to Fabian
his team might just know the answer to
assistance with ordering until like 6 but already
played guess 464 like 6 here
of course there are no alternatives and
You can’t give 20, so 5 5g go and
that's when it really starts
this whole game starts qualifiers up to 5
Maybe there are some discount codes?
very late what since i'm already 23
maybe on through e-8, here I am, perhaps that's all
in fact, they begin to tell us
some things about who is on what exactly
on a visa is going to navigate but
again created some kind of threat or
black just prepared for under 20
let's say the threat is not winning the threat of some
unloading horses again harris would 4-series
b5 not sure how good
again, it really depends
naturally what do whites do
move is another situation in which
would you like to start showing these
options but you need to get down to business
White to make some move into the groove a3
appas is not so easy to make, well, let's say
from her as they again from to 4 first to 5
say first again slope to 5 and three
again, the move is pretty bad from the point
it seems to me that it is because
creates a field worked for to him even
here let's say if would go 2 by 4
hard yes work hard so they immediately said
because on knight b3 she served two and
the horse can get lost there
traveled alone at least one too but
I thought that somehow it could be black
although this is also aiming 2 yes, I took it
her name is bad she is bad
so either one more simpson was around
already just a figure to eat in the distance
if you're greedy, but of course, 1 too
suits well ka it's 60 monstrous
finally, four whites will go until
rice taxes one more move which
looks terrible but maybe not
is like 7 to maybe me
the pool is just right but the truth is that's when 7
also considering where the horse is standing, so far
owners one because it should
dessaline also went fc 8 up on this
factory 8 there equestrian since not 5's
mind very very risky larvae
fingers shabit will not end with a hare
6 white eat quite a lot of mother
actually this is how black can play
directed at 3 is quite possible
do and cube 4 to 5 out more generally
plan move fierce 8 just defends the end
a6 before if before a3 it was let's say
in the current fingers of the angry vape green
threat his date after version 8 pictured
23 black full right to just move away
need 5 in the interior jacque they threatened again
again the horse is not himself not for everything and so
say the goalkeeper hate that's why
whites might just be forced to
walk a3 a4 and when you are probably better
do immediately well and here is ft-1
get it right one makes a move
in if actually I wanted to say that
renews the menace of the groove and everything is here
such a not very groove and because
odessa one step away from 1 it's obviously a move
very specifically in the caves finds equal
the committee is now on a double take and on c6
finish off
again, apparently discarded rather like this
in order, it probably makes sense to call
owner 2 and in this fingers go again
same owners 8 can even immediately and
c5 can be considered because Berta
I don't know how to gesture weakness
right but anyway
of course it seems quite probable to me
because they threaten again if we don't
want to go it's 6 and probably need at least
somehow 24 but after the horse again still not
it is not very clear where to retreat with these
figures because the scientist is essentially
they just take on b5 twice in the majority
houses say to queen 2 to informing 2 or
heart two looks pretty decent
just took took another 4 out of 4 by antics
4 each, so maybe there can be a queen
b3
this is dc-6 then c 66 so this
the feeling that in the market rikudo will
press on 6 and fabiana hits immediately
us 6 co-owner 6.5 rook will go to c2
Do you have all the parks like this by the way
curious
some kind of curious but do not forget at all
pro delay we be in if listen to our
reports and
and realized that it makes sense 10 10 seconds
you have sense at home 10 seconds on
every turn because when after the farm
six spheres dc 6v if I thought about it
generally outlandish yes such a feeling before
time is a pity in a game of rapid chess
but given that time is wasted if
make a move student seconds can where
that makes sense
well and here
must or go owners 8 probably from
it seems to me or to be 5 is not right
where else hot club 4
but it seems to me again, I don't know
why do blacks ask forgiveness for what
black in its all complications up in
especially today I am the owner of the sims not
will kill almost anything, you have to give up c7 pawns
a7 is generally black here
have some game for
for a pawn for a pawn but why is it necessary
when the position in general does not look
so critical i understand another
hand income do well go here go
don't get yourself back on dc gone now
maybe someone 4
although why not go don't know wife and 4
I now realized that I
considered the option and 4 cm to 3 forgetting
I can see about it today, but I have
four in general is not very desirable, but
I just wanted. again on the next
apparently the most natural way you can
some rabbit move and 5 on then
apparently black just walks at six and
White has no good square because
finally 4 big blacks
happy to start mass size so
what
Yes, I'm five in my life, I know where to go
now if you get a boatman there are no these
6 you can try here
from 4
to clarify this elephant a little after all
like 6 cavalry 6 some kind of
Rashkin. black people don't want
yes, and I would also have a lot of weakness
agree
I agree with the previous speaker
maybe this is just ripe and worth it
try
until even 5 is played and that too
quite an interesting moment
because the [ __ ] up to this point the game
absolutely instantly obvious what's obvious
ready yes yes bringing owner 2 surprise
cannot become, and here it is already spent and
I think a couple of minutes to the next
move looks curious enough
he remembers to eat more than one
possible solution of scientists in principle is not
so bad and after that drink another move
sushi by the way, here's about the alternatives on
wait a second maybe an alternative move
get along two [ __ ] like her 5 very
strangely studied I don't know there f6
threading processions of our symbol yes well
try to tell that cavalry 6
actually, well, it's just to beat on
axes can be play positional
put 10 we sit down that I'm still a husband
try not to give up any pawns in
in this sense, well, yes, all the same, you are clean
the quality is given, I understand that it's too much
that looks very nice but it's you
expect
look for what we lack figures yes you don't
there must still be one horse
nasty conditional top bishop
somewhere on and 7 to what then is it possible that so
you can talk about it 8 nevertheless
already played all the same decided to prepare
dc5 well, yes, there are still on e4
hasan to 3 therefore
you can’t immediately drive a horse black, no doubt
want to go chain and now on us still
great comfort before principled
approach get along 1
but here it is apparently my previous
the idea looks pretty good
and now 4 because keep ladino
lazy and impossible so set the stone
two years on the water should go out but also
now we beat 25 by the way and
there could be a 2 plus beam lift here
dresses 1.4 looks like absolute
we give equality and since we keep under
field control up to 7 is important only not
yawn like her 5 principle but
taking the rook seems to me these problems
respects very much yes we have limited
this horse on a horse to 4 let's go on and 8 well
and then slowly the whole figure
change of course you know that
maybe you could finally take it
on the shore of the city with also send an elephant to
protection from there is additionally to this
game along the line of the hips, but here it is all the same
can be transferred
according to 35 you were 15 nicholas cleaner but
became we here is not so bad of course
scientists as it might seem
and in if he thinks if Kanye 5 then well
because cains evening i don't run
should not therefore apparently not just
I want again again, but after dc
here it seems obvious to me
improved version of the same
because if you want you can even
you can still turn it on for everyone at 6
I don't know if we need it again
this tactic is always pretty easy
yawn and you can, in case of refusal, the husband
poke what is not necessary nice what is not
need Bilan to give such additional
opportunities so let's just go
owner of 525 bc
hanging on barely and on cattle we will render her 4
let's go to combo what looks the most
naturally already at six very decent
the threat doesn't look like the scientists are there
at least some problems that is to rise
one
do not have time to arrange goals a little
say sent 11 ac15 if already
there was a pawn on 3
then after dc, the ranks would probably be at
case tangible problems but a3 white
do not have time to go because on this
scotsman a4 and again impossible
hold vladin line c because
11:04 just getting caught
so so wait some saw how
I turned the way for what faces either
4 but do not see protection as a thread between before
radiation alone is apparently not a move somehow
find
and again after her 525 me 55 me
went to
some position say stands 5d rook
father, except that she then slept, but
he probably started the outcome
tell started vaults 6 but then understood
what can be scheduled a walk is not up to
3 to 2 actually yes it was no because
what if I took it somehow not very
comfortable to hold the pawn c5 black
bandage
and maybe it’s convenient you can while walking
money 8 yes, or let's say there are 7 yes
I would only have it 4 percent so it is necessary
maybe it's the camp you
if the whites took they took then we also took
took on 2 before some race starts
here it looks like the seventh is a pity we have worse
there are pawns on the kingside.
such a position may not be
knew 7 before they could villains 2 start
to the store
will have to return revived here somehow
the whites went
it was maybe it's not so necessary and
draw because even that's in probation
saying it's such a position is still white
bits in 2 to white in general do not risk in
or a bunch of checks yes for both sides
well, yes, and besides that, I can basically
start probably 54 they don't know what
I am thinking about this structure, but there is
such a suspicion that they should not black and
much to fear must be order
procreate 11 5 played dc well and will you
is that this is some kind of send we
showed this option for 4 combi is
two here in general not at all and no
problems are not why in our view
owns the question well here they go by
still on the photo and lines that we
discussed
so we actually and how is mobile on 1
or 2 would return to 4 yes we have
at least we thought it wasn't.
in general even as a question
put some difficulty before
Yes, I thought how realistic
black's chances to play well, it looks like
there is conditionally saying that's right now fabi
I thought, that is, I have two in no
there are no rebuttals, but if it rains
play say bc
it's on bc3 suddenly start i think
with nectar and the world knows what interest
appears well yes how is it before 5 5 tell me
that there is no reason why we
it's admitting it's not a game of escape
it is not clear why
well, it's just that there is no disaster for her
what didn't happen a lot of black people need
one than it is better than a horse beats for two
completely incomprehensible hobby thinks but
I think that it will come the same as there
what that he is voicing this to you in general
dryly so the first batch is developing
tourism discussion theoretical
discussions in modern chess are often
it looks like this, I'm thinking on whom beta
2 can be dressed cd1 doesn't bother me but i
I do not understand why after the spent
must be bad I don't see any
tactical strikes i.e. white
get some tempo button on jumping
horseback but we're all so secure on
sun lounger 8 again there is magic 5 well even
if without further ado went to them in the 4-ku not
up to 7 tons up to 7 water up to 7 here went with
everyone
and on let's say the rook axis I have a move
coica 6 i have had enough to do before 8
if you want, well, in general, it feels like
should not be scientists bad but also besides
we can try this on horse 5
make some tricky move instead
the same slang 8 is 54
but these four are connected exactly 900
rearrange the rake on the horse much more
correct fully the queen giver
the pawn is still alive. live and rook
we drive with a good climb in general it is
some, too, this game feels like
not but rather on the defeat of the victory under
bush pool but then again
it's not easy to scare adults
that's why
looks very very reliable and started
well thinks fabi nevertheless thinks
not again if it's all theoretical
the date line is a little strange what he thinks
here but maybe try to understand
why if went to this position why
namely barking is not but two nevertheless
played
in general, there were no problems and no
I think
after the rook one stone by 4 has you
bath up to 4
sbs play well or knight d4 on start again
we all the time continuing to remind about
the fact that field 8 is not a passive field but
otherwise very safe and comfortable.
position for the elephant where he is optional
covers with a lid everyone leaves from any
enjoyed im holding yea yea vladi 1
km to 4 is already on the board if it happens
think maybe take on b6 i.e.
like this structure yes that is
as long as we have all the wishes for
1 and Black cannot play a rook in
everyone but they own d8 it seems to me though
would not 4 even than to tony an 2 4 elephant
and 8 on a horse for 4 do not attack because
bullet 4 under control while black want
own up to 8 tell me 5 up too true
it is not clear how white can use
effectively light figures yes stands as if
the same 2 seems to be the control of nick 80
attack anything come on so on the past
Feels like blacks are generally in control
everything they need is here
check therefore
so rain whom i 1 to 4 up on the board
now this is the position yet another
time thinks in if dream wondering expense
Yes, again, here it is necessary to recall that before
rebuilding may not be so easy
regime
here's the classic chess on a quick yes
it is clear that all experienced people played here
tie-break but nevertheless if this
comes up to one minute before the game on
the delay is still very big.
debit 7 play if
well, here again bc probably too
no big deal, but it looks more logical
give white even in principle, but
Bassem camp is not, therefore, earthly
help c8 prada one pair may not be
changed no big deal after
would cycle not 580 hunting not up to 7 which
apparently water up to 8 true black
bounce otherwise it would be pretty
scary 6 have to beat then already shantou
black bounce like that or with a thread
gotta family hanging on a horse hanging well and
in general and since it would not be 80 1 white
after book 8 latista 2 how is he a walker
hasn't got out of here yet everyone has to go
horses
eat a pawn
don't risk white voltaic 8 pretty
strong threat in this bus position
it is clear how not to react Omsk to
maybe just finished playing here
played a little, yes, it’s really necessary here
think about how to solve
Equation problems for 9 2 move a little
cooperative can king and 8 can 6
unacceptable brother but dressed 8 at the end
in the end give on horseback 6 just beat
candles so yes, you just need to don’t
lose the presence of mind but again not
I understand
What's Wrong After A Either Imagine Babes 80
beat the rook
beat beat yes how would we take away the ladies
where open lines but left completely
limited material and
black on the sly
will bring out squeezed installed 5 some not
5 would not threaten to bring her back he c8
bye at 66 to 7 till bye bye 8 you
let's say something like an elephant and so but this again
same yes it is walk walk play position
maybe not, but also a layer up to 6 in it then
problems will begin, but somehow we don’t
hibernates water until 6 successful anime so far
went king 80 to 6 minutes
allotted 5
danton qe7 still even but bright at the end
wanted one
well yes it is important to them because I
gave 16 sense
exactly the same position
forcibly issued to the end of 2nd street
put 1 pawn on b7 change pawns on b
here and nothing at all
15 15 on your screens that is the time
think there is a myth resentment completely
obviously choosing between
taking on c5 with a pawn and not water
some intermediate move knight c6 yes me
here, too, I think it may be jorhate
played contemplating the move to retire cheryl late
6 dB and additionally drives the rook out
7 rows are worse that they don’t even let the horse in
what are these clearings rook a d7 on him
just bc and questions what is the threat on
outcome and by the way Crimea bc probably is
walker not again because we need 6 now
yes, by the way, very decent because
Polina was climbed by the action of Korolev 8 for the sake of
got politics whether it's not at all
back on the assumption that for a second a
reach at the same time
you can think about patrick's horse beating 5
by the way, you can want cavalry 6
repeat can be read paste
of course, but if the rook goes down then
then in general all questions are removed
automatically if necessary of course
check sbc
yourself for but by the way maybe not stupid and 4
there is an additive yes, well, for now, apparently the United States
or in that position check-dag he 2 4 we give
check stone f1
we left on and 8 strongly-strongly again on 7
and it is very important to win that the scientist and
sit down niches that lure in deceit
expelled need war very much would be
the problems probably turn out to be
the problem is not so much with whites because
horses up to 4 is strictly the only thing
something to attack and forged on
something else and then shah I'm sorry
step step up islam and 8 and no way
save beige 7 . I swear to you
objectively hopelessly well strayed in general
fabiana demonstrated good knowledge
materiel in this game given questions
which we asked were not actually
looks so complicated on again
[music]
you can immediately start talking about
maybe in if at all believe that he
need to carry weight without a blitz match
but i don't think it's that much
it's obvious that fave play blitz so badly
secondly, well, the white party is always
what will you be and there was no strategy
to match the white party people try though
would minimally use the first run
as if he had such a strategy
us points he already made a draw with black
comments you can once tried without
risk nothing happened let's play
damn, actually the water from now is like this
colorless not someone's to come
the second game with black we twist fabiano
caruana what what feed pothole
filing very seriously dacha very very
serious only gets better with
for years therefore
but he himself is completely incomprehensible how white
can black tasks be translated
the rook went there to attack the pawn
need until they again
looks very decent and try not to
let him go to b3
Yes, it’s still a little awkward with white, but
there went one go consults
spying up consults off the telly and
another field but here is a rook 1pc rather
just getting along one in succession is possible
some and 2 and 3 such a neat game
even the horse again unacceptably got it already
that pawn is hanging honey in all these
options constantly on somewhere there is an elephant
e2 but now that we also have a move
why is it clear that black should
be absolutely fine compa 4 have
I absolutely think you are a cool move
red created a palette so hint
what does it take to have
I don't think anything bad will happen
if korolev 8 go to role 8 i thought
there somehow else ends 55 and 4 really why
give white steps then why give white
whale geometric attempts to attack
on propaganda
by the way, maybe in general this is the idea
aka 5
but she's very amplified then the king up
8 what to write pawn h7 we want to give away
fire on 4 seems to me looks the most
naturally preparing
good answers will get better one on horseback 5
we can do up to 8 most likely
to study in the wrong direction, we continue to change figures
or online on a horse pen can be possible
go to the 6th now finally yes yes and
for which up to 7 to remember enough grandfathers 8
account great better on revision for
black and after the water to 1 but all rise and
well, let's beat it all go not a big fan
I thought that I would somehow move into
some completely equal 4 by 4 fabi
do bye photos 76 system 6 that's how
divorce
stopping all these pro lenin same five
ten since the tip of perch 4 was
almost the only productive
the plan that we discussed the ideas of it
don't let me seem pretty
actually no matter how it sounds
so amateurish and make a window
here's a war in this position because he
there were some motives
last with last horizontal
it is certainly clear that
it seems yes it seems that if it was
some kind of micro initiative, that's all
it ends and it gets better again
one has a move to understand well, where I think
that more than one move on the most
looks natural if you're on a horse
again before forcing the form of fellow and 3 well
here you can think about the answers
hoses 8 let's say there is some move
sun 6 to understand whether it works or not
because I already have the maximum and neither
one would very much like for a big one
put the elephant took took we here somehow
find a way to exchange pawn prices for pawn b2
Well, just in case, just if you start with
25 4 it turns out that early or passive
ryan when you end up lead
it was to this size that the elephant played
f1
if it does the same
I change elephants myself through
across the field f1 bishop ifr-1 korolev one
your here there is no feeling here at all
easy should be a draw just some
combination of moves c4k on the 5th center
generally non-whites should not be in
able to prevent complete
elimination on the queenside but also after
this four by four is unlikely, yes, or
by the way, you can sip Hellas
85 number
summed up to the minutes they then somewhere
korolev 8 and 7 you might think
white is also late in 3 especially
has no prospects but up to 3 is acceptable
translation too slow
getting used to the color is almost always
the estuary will also lead to an exchange, and exactly how
weight blown b5
ferzikovo flank therefore, well, in general, here
such a structure is not exactly the same here
the Catalan advantage is small yes yes yes
of course not not not usually talked about
in the directory when trying to play on
a small preponderance of water would be 5 to 25
fabiano actually plays
well done and one well it looks like a party just
the end is nearing the soul will get better
that swerve up would get better 80cc 2
somehow looks, well, not very menacing
customer over 45 looks good in
the answer is that there is a suspicion that
white just go where there is a move get along up
6 but again went to the commission asked again
what exactly we want is not clear
completely and understandably check not
yawn movie some tactics ambassador face
b8 well, I think that with a huge probability
just get along 2 fret b2 there are a few
held 5 but again white is not
wins such finger positions by all
even just pool water
and Bela need there to scientists monstrously
badly stood all figures to have though
would whale grounds continued by the way here
rather monstrously ill standing worthy of all
figures here is a very similar position to you
the face itself lost the city but here it is
when you sit there and it was my way in
at some point four by four until
I think the potato was on e5
crushed it probably important sales flow
at least it gives some micro clues
and here is the correct big beech
spacious leaves much better figure
everyone stood that is what we're talking about type
personally not whose it took quite, completely
tied position not yet played own
a 8 because the whole hurry
nowhere to go yet king kovalev 8
on though there's no way you can go king 80
analogy to whole cube 4 look
absolutely adequately created all these
horses lawyer all these threats so far
quietly let down the king in empoli 7
so that even there was no one to intrude on
lines along line d
so comfortable choosing fabian
you know something like this
there is such a plan, but if you look for
the possibility of it in the face how to make it difficult
of making draws and black pieces
horses 1 to 3 maybe but again in
in the end let's go as if 4 guess
let's not let him go three we will continue
quietly enhance the composition of the rest
league also does not seem to be any
there were problems and
I would like to say that you kind of expect to
from some kind of rapid chess
acceleration
more than something more spicy more
emotional yet very measured
very measured vasilisa play on
there was no bump
case yes i.e. not principle option c
24 here's a [ __ ] in the debut it's the same but it
trying to actually play one of
the sharpest options up to 100 thousand
white is still being dried
natural here is short then he has hiv
believes deposit fat and more than a6
there are more photos 6 could 8 sort of like
is considered more accurate here very
often starts absolutely gambit on
game because the pawn on d4 is lucky
win back a lot u in many cases
it just doesn't work out well
that's why
6 just pavé in general was ready
beeped yes what is ready to play
sharp obscure positions but understanding is not
will not meet korolev 8 while returning
afraid there were eight positions on the board
queens 8 well, that is, nothing special
supernatural all the moves we
we guess enviably take a break so much
many all types three pieces on the board
so not much
maybe maybe not even moves
so yes, and the pause is long enough
so we have time for all reasonable moves
sort out yes we have after that of course
say yes, yes, well, she put on makeup
2 soul sequins and four white
can come and you need 2 back and
ask if it's time for us to go, isn't it time
us seconds for which the owner of two cubes 4
from this no
if there is u does it give me something i have two
donations
but then again if I want nothing draw
maybe, but it's also possible
just for example just this one not from
nuts rather all black this toes are not
losing objectively speaking
under them. they must seem to me
at least some kind of
there are outlines of how to swim
black want to lose dnr on
should not lose on topics 3
chastise i 10 as usual thickness and
care log in sometimes try
count at least a move how to make a draw
flank 4 strongly does nothing c3 on
king and 22 it's time to go to kindergarten
the beginning of db-1 some kind of diana will agree
as we did before if the whites move
king first forward then after the center
how would find a role to 1 i can't guess
patil 12 and here already such white can
share for victory but they are on occasion
it's against losing let's get back to
what is happening 40 44
but probably the only horse for 4
try but try torture strictly
the only yes because if otherwise you
must walk the water to 2 just repeat
move are 4 to 3 it's a matter of losing
a pawn would be two bottoms that feels like this
what is provided in this idea is not clear
yes, come on, women, if ours is not watching somewhere
on the board even look at looks back
there's something to distract the tournament hall
yes yes we are four
went well, and again, strictly speaking, not
I really understand why we can't say go
rook rook bb-8 can even do
nothing would be 8 I thought to take and on c5
the truth here I just can
to arise here is the same situation smartly
ice uncomfortable figures to such a horse
somehow I don't want to
objectively it's so many cells yes
get up
but 2 say probably the toughest
finally u2 cavalry 218 or by the way
saying that's still thought canned q54 too
ask why on the plow they are worse
narrowed
well, just like aida64 on don't jump jump
queen 2 3 yes somewhere in how but combined 2
yes go welcome to it
Extermination Begins Tasks of the Planets Museum
I like the move in general 18 I think that
mathematically should be the cleanest
decision but it is clear that all the same these
kunio 300 confuses you
let's not go to 3 now let's play
someone 4 break it seems this is it
pretty good solution because
compared to previous positions
influences and and white which is not even
sent us scientists problems
the white horse was also sent to the side
somewhere, well, that is, it's already a matter of taste, yes
that is, any of these need to feel
which of these options is
black keeps somewhere a little bit maybe
be on the defensive
but in general, it's certainly simple
draw
documents and yet played why
if there is nothing white there, of course not
where they can not release therefore
scare your as much as possible
the enemy tries but this type
said that's fabi yes that's the moment when
there was a groove and the choice of such a move
sort of here is the king f8 then luckily actually
deed very competently because any
emerging now endgame they mush
lie down in the presence of the king them 8 does
them
much more to say even this
will deceive you either
and I have mine like it's my special
way of making nothing i 8 final i 8
rook 44 you can go tell me sex or
or Solovetsky does not give fellow sadist
suggesting one naturally sheathed
really here I am alone and then here to put
just rook 4 rudder 2 we are running somewhere
there, well, even such studs driving fields
game shot
c4 yes, at least this is me
probably of all would like to allow
least of all don't know why to meddle
four somber kings 3 here goes
will see that therefore reasons
it's a shame because the water bataev attempt
make a whit someone translate into four
by four
rook 8 years trying to do anything on
understanding killing certainly have the right to
existence is here and once again here is one
option that confused me on the whole
this territory was rook b3 fritter 11 4
and now here go on the fret bo3 played
now go king say and one
c3 king to 112 a4 fret beat 2 and rook
write there is a feeling that it is
trying to lose the party instead of winning
say vadim floor 2
again 12 mines in the district center, here I am up to 7 by 6
radio 7 how it should be you
win well, yes, and in the country once created
checkpoint polyline already well, actually
after this in March, we have not created a law
walk-through polyline right up to instead with
beat just on c5 here you are
empty dastan everything is over
not very, very long first batch
objectively
in if went to the central opening
line and how often are parties 2 good
trained chess players black
demonstrated but felt again
I don't know much about this league
perhaps even some important micro
amplification somewhere and
fabiana made a good draw strongly without
special problems and not much straining and
will play the next brocade with white
it will start with figures, again we are for sure
we do not know how much we impose that in
one o'clock in the afternoon on it charlemagne food we have
remains 17 minutes us pretty custard
a big pause which we think than than
let's fill in the scheme at some point
us but sushi while the water is beautiful
picture I believe that the judge should still
his white glove like snooker yes it is
put on and wipe the figure would see
still ride out on yeah if it all
a special device was made
to put the figure exactly in the center
glue is needed somewhere we tried very hard
make a move and 2 and 4 shadow liked both
she occupied fields a4
do you tell the referee so
you point your finger even vomiting the enemy
played integration call the referee
says that this pack Linda war
two cities
who carefully remove the boards
cleans cleans with a white glove and
returns to the same place, but for now we
not yet achieved then not finished off the cabin
this progress
well, he's a little bit not on me a little bit
upset such a flow of party 1 well
yes of course for rapido want want
something more slurry lunar new we have
Mamedyarov did not hit, so yes, of course
such pawn runs of the same given
parties stagnated and talk about
failed tie-breaks in the cup
sinful then there of course the very presence
Carlson would have everyone for a stimulus well
firstly, yes, and plus two scenarios with
which one of the swordsmen accurately hit
would be in a tie-break without any
once upon a time there was a victory of the Mamedyars and or a victory
Grischuk and since they had a victory
black figures, well, both I
I think that they would very much revive the current
course of struggle in any tournament with
shortened control
and not with shortened control either
wanting I complained yesterday in this studio
the fact that he was tired very tired of
so interesting, yes, because we have
it felt like it was full of impact energy
leg and actually new even energy
just burn with toffee and he himself came and
it's obvious that he knows better and that's it
internally wait here but the energy then
there is nevertheless that is now when
Let's imagine what happens when
I didn’t recognize this, it’s scary to think and
spoke about the fact that over the past 3 months
played
75 may not be service five parties on
something very much but also was
at the tournament, it affected probably not
every day parties nevertheless
being in a tournament imposes
still its psychological imprint
and you don’t rest so calmly as
would rest
let's say at home in a circle well first
the party is a little bit faded but
we are waiting for party 2 where fabiana will be
white I understand that he is easy in out
the woods will not let go of the white pieces again
A lot depends on the opening
just like in this party we are not in tune
suppose that if you wanted to do
a draw at the age of 30 was simply not surprising
enemy choice and where he could not
put not a single problem
so in if also black very very
strong debut repertoire
so let's see what that fabiana will be
with this to do yesterday I watched a little
his preparation for this match preparation
went through Swedish
and in general the young man looked
satisfied and not much how to say no
it felt like he was being swallowed up
will give you this pressing there before absorb
thoughts about the upcoming playoffs and therefore
that the cries and the heavy figure of steel poses
moto her, resounded resounded and there
beautiful company and our swedish
chess
well, yes, there is an ironic maxim constantly with
some caustic comments yes there
lego or out hidayata then later came
levon and such a standard couple
like Ivan Iksanov who are in this game
also constitute a very harmonious
creative so give me even powerful
so I played with them for a while, but I
I'm not at all fit, so I'm like
just saw someone qualified
replacement man for his own with a cry I
rescued jumped up from the table and ran away and
without me there, in general, everything was in order
yeah well, watch again at two o'clock
local time, then after 13 minutes I
I understand the second game will begin in five
minutes before it we will be back on the air
sell and up use make
your right to take a little break
stay with us hope second
the party will be much more saturated
[music]
you hung then now useful rollers
received by agreement
son with boyfriend blitzen simple captcha on
minsk feature douglas without soldering in circles
cycles now club stella accordion player ntr
brooches and not countries he collected it with
morphing
warehouse now
he was
of the game + 1
[music]
he was from alois explorer
official crap table now
odessa firefox os x
flash online game pc per hour
we now and mr alfred
like the world
voice
from world of tanks in space in this world
ft alex art and design who i
exhibitions
mcfly musical movie from him by the way a
left tiny love is mash-up
original and there visa
now we are with you muzzle now heviz
gosias phial parts without addition
[music]
and falls asleep begin with the world of
tanks
[music]
your game
explay n1 this he got
cheese-boron class from the fly region of the world
as a la faim
mayn yell expense
[music]
well, back to the day of thai break
off
will start in just a few minutes
second batch yes not long left until before
the second batch is clear that from rapido
is always waiting for some
incendiary fireworks but considering
that play two serious serious
dictating who only curtains yes no
so much even follow mother eats it herself
needless to say it is a serious debut
a check that plus just that
played two tough events in a row
for which for which probably some
some people were already a little
wastes just what Fabian needs plus
to this, of course, it is necessary to think about
how important it is to win one game
chess in this tie-break compared
let's say with the need to save
some
ammo dry for london so
a lot of course will be in the second
parties depend precisely on which
debut choice and will do will do
chess players because both of them can
play very interesting spicy but it happens
what we see is what we saw in
first batch here
theoretical discussion leading to
[ __ ] equality and emasculation
it's not just in classic chess
it happens that it’s clear what is given, so I started
finally read the chat we just remembered
their dacha duties started so chad
hello everyone in the chat ask us
still why aronian don't play what for
that this is only the limit another other
comrade competitions
abscesses already talked about this at the beginning
broadcast, that is, it was decided
that the first place is a single cab
will not be played, and even for this
wife joked about doctor ginnie
ryksa sintel let it go that we are so
wanted someone new to win, but
these three guys they've already won
one-off and findus so decided
draw breath we now have a new one
the winner which is actually 3
the winner is three in one hydra
heads and hydra yes this is type for
another sashana of the tie-break tournament in
which is up for fourth place in
final tournament us often in london and
whether he has already secured a place in London for himself
he can rest today than I'm sure
he actually deals with questions
again we have a little pause
we can take a break from all of these
events I was asked what I think about
current Super Final
and and its compare worn compared to
previous superfinal I don't think that
it is fundamentally different from
previous in the superfinal this year
plays more young chess players then
there is there you can go to this in two ways
you can say that there from the point of view
the average ranking of the stash participants
weaker than the previous ones, we can talk about
what per turnover is the maximum here
such an exhibition
chess future of russia because well
again, with the possible exception
Esipenko
with a man whom we talked a lot in
flow
previous two tournaments all names
which have been heard lately
people if you take talented youth yes
here they are all represented there by michael
Sobolev coach of talented youth and
actually talented young people there
side allegory of Pauline who doom
and in general I'm not a very good version
about the fact that this is the weakest in the whole
the history of the championship of russia but this is not having
that's what it means all the same probably
since 2004 when they became
come
completed because it is clear that there
any Swiss tournament shuts up for
belt with ease, but even if you take
such an approach still plays there
play those who don't remember hailstones aseev I don't remember
story in the village of Kamenka Tomashevsky
andreikin i'm not gods yes yes i know why
what is he then if if
if you don't like it, what's the solution?
any again that is stepping on that
colleagues mineral here I commented
collective here and vladimir pain juicier
do not always play the superfinal sasha too
looking for played here what kind of people are missing
but overall it's still stellar
perfect
I have these complaints and yes and look
ask us what will happen to
goblet proper goblet sen-hyun do
physical yes yesterday discussed yesterday
also the question of who will get what
piece of cup and
fabi said that he didn't care at all
you don’t have to give him the cup, this is it
bottom is the pedestal on touches worth
a cup of gives will be quite satisfying
I don't know today we'll see the girl
regarding should be ceremony
closing on which all these questions so
or otherwise be allowed, well, and here
little by little we are getting closer to the beginning
actually the second installment between the studio
the clock should already be given now
the go-ahead must be given a start on what
there are 4 to 4 probably e4 though again
berlin and
and you need to have something for Berlin then
what are you if you do not indulge he will
of course he can, and not only Berlin, yes
well, Fabiana goes to 4 because there
frozen nearby there is a feeling that there
a little easier to tie something
and groups than Berlin, well, and that's if
yes-ah-ah, we have already seen it against
karjakina vs karjakina metro fine
worked against measles what approach
pretty quickly got a huge advantage
but in general it was indicated immediately after
parties
we were asked by other participants of the tournament
don't you know why black people don't
made such or such a move in this
parties instead of what they actually
done so far repeating some
I think the participants of the tournament asked
why didn't danil make such a draw
clear, I softened even partly a quote from
some participants in the right and even
some technicians are not exactly perplexed
why why couldn't it be
make a forced draw at some
moment but now came out already dodged away from
party caravan karyakin queen up to 5
parties move made was not there it was a dream
up to 700 the same 55 looks much more combat
satisfaction is highly welcome
of course the idea if you play here
finally we have a big one in which
logic of things before 5 o'clock I will say this and
there is some forced draw but
I want to say that in this fingers
forced to do anything wrong
easy that is easier black seems to me
preponderance here and gain than do not
than to make a forced draw like this
fund is strong
but there is an extra pawn, it’s not visible yet
how white is going to win back on c4
awkward black figures stand well how are you
normal enough Catalan
compensation is clear that white is probably
compared lost some but is it
4 now this is already interesting this will get boring
river db4 fierce 2can d3 and in these
positions white
it happens at least immediately up to 5 bikes while syllables
3 then sometimes try to candy one
walk
but even I counted the photo so that 4
of course there is and then you are here
small vodka
how many 6 is probably at least a cubic 3
although he looks like countries take and 23
tankred was not in good condition, yes, but again
when we have the opportunity to go to
mining the whole course of calcium in 4 ladies to
take over the last one you need
really need to consider this
need to consider is it true it can
be very handy critical opportunity
to be trustworthy
but age thought again before that
the moment he played it was instantly clear that
party who fabian most recently
won a very strong chess court u
everyone in front of
drew in if me attention getting ready for
today's match or maybe even
right after the game happens when you have
in front of people show some
relatively fresh idea you come to
number and spend half an hour there but
real you can see everything-everything is recorded yes yes
a 4 first and offers a deal to
finally consumers are sure to
petersen because just in ace 23 23
on the list of Sochi there we are finally
we can prove everything now
happens actually but again here
if you go back a little 3 on
monitor that if the one who is not not quite
understood light from above need 2 to 5 knight f3
dc short so weird catalan
which is black play samba 4 and white already
went to some center that they usually don't
doing so early in catalonia cavalry 64
karyakin here the elephant went 7 to 75
surely there is it possible to gain
scientists from this if went to int again
white instantly returned to the connector on t2
over some hints of the game how much 5
so the word symbols brought deed
siding by Slavs 4 went very fast
black go end by 4 if the queen goes
on the way such a field now this
spokes 4 on will be extremely extremely difficult
i'm bad yes
me with fields so played rd2 with
so that it is obvious who beats 3 to beat
queen and on b5 to have all sorts of different options
usually it was just walks there would be three
such a sign to take you can jump while
you can drive up the initial i to the fact that
even such a structure often gives
white very, very decent
compensation depending on
how much study will become awkward shapes
rather embarrassing elephant on r-7 specifically
here you want to end up pretty
embarrassing because there is pressure polyne
and let's say at 7 it looks decent again
while here is an elephant and in the 4th how it protects
pawn c7 say 6 to it 5 such in general
typical positions in which White has
long term compensation
they are not likely to threaten anything immediately
will be on such a good long-term
compensation, well, plus to this, of course, but
bo5 you can take your time in threes
can start gathering they 5 on cover up
d3 now plays square until 3 until then
look for some kind of amplification but here
instead of all this
6 to white instantly buzz off time
surprised again can not be allowed panda
3 so do more forgot to fight for
remote this to walk somewhere or a2 a3
or maybe up to 2 and 2 attacking
fourteen
here you do not start to have questions
water how serious black this pawn
want to keep because all the same
play some kind of position
structure centered on White at
material equality is
and it's worse and they don't know how much worse
but it's definitely worse
how to keep on c4 not quite on well here
there's a certain foot six floors while urgently
if if not really worried about
can be aesthetically maintained by almost everyone
in 6 let's say beat beat beat version 2
come on and walk the individual to this topic me
a few problems in what is now threatening
b2b 3
to the persistent not oddly yes they don't
very lucky there as soon as we set to
don't have three problems start with
sell life don't worry about
aesthetic content that in 564
somewhere if she doesn't bother at all
found us alone forget about the aesthetic
content on though it might be time
go there until service 7 some pass
we are tired of the shirt-front on the last one too
in general, if it's black to have time to go to 54
this whole game starts pretty start
seem pretty serious all of a sudden
makes sense, yes
apart from move f6 what do we have
chances are we don't have quiet moves like
elephants 8 and then after the version you
version 2 feels like a c4 pawn
the c4-pawn is not easy to defend
offhand I don't see how or protect more
that and most likely from him well and after
this yes here is a conversation about what can
maybe you can think of how they can
be eat at least
marten 6 in order to beat it is necessary then
because blacks can calmly west
four things in the version let's say the [ __ ] inside
well, how did the mini take cut the e5 chain for how
at least there is such a situation in
black souls just better extra pawn
a pawn after all and a pawn only therefore
services 8 white must under heart 2
the move looks almost
forced not because we are so
urgently need to operate only c4 though
and this is important because just the top 2
extremely generally underfoot
other pieces of the bishop s1 on the hand from and
to deduce the principle of the bulk of some
create so create a game that is all
2 but wait maybe my wasted there
stopped in two directions you did not
stop i'm just trying to find another
move and I can’t show well how then
difficult
besides frising into something to come up with but
here you can probably for example
go to this position let's say to the heart
8 and then we start to drive something on
royal r4 same 45 forward because
scientists an extra pawn with a note on b6 he
frankly, there is no decoration after
thought immediately has no less than 6 in response
our hobby immediately hits and walks the sacrum
21st bella's first garden a
to be honest, it feels like
such a thing for one quick batch though
he would have gone so hard with the Koryaks, therefore
people into the classics so maybe I don't
right because, well, right here at
black
an extra pawn
add
there won't be any coming may at all
will never be played
and at the same time for whites but in comparison with
other gambits with them options to the ticket
whites are not quite not quite they are hooks yes not
quite obvious trump card therefore can
they don't worry too much about it.
but he plays there further bishop e3 somehow
start pawn hk for example mean
that there are almost always five of them d5 I was thinking
over to go like the fierce 8
then rook a 8 to 8 suspicious
spend at 5:05
it will be very difficult to defend
field control to 5 black rather
they won’t be able to take everything, therefore, having
here you are for immediately and at five on
five will obviously walk and d because
what he gives you can’t let go of course
let's say food, but here what is the volume allowed
you can think about this horse then
apparently not beat beat and the course of the whole d6 is very
a good field is occupied for an elephant
again, some games, but not a4 at all
followed until the move up to 5 packs of everyday use
then 24
if again, then undoubtedly for whites
all these positions have improved because
what sent 3 will create
a grave threat to myself 6 well apart from
positionally such a threat, especially in
this fingers six and six balls
goat d6 and I still don't see why
killed so well but so in general
responsible gaming frankly except
of course there are codes, I again well
let's say they row what you need again for me too
how they say goodbye to eat and such a move
while attacked h7 we want c6 bit by bit if
queen and solar version 4 then hangs
walk to 70 on and 6 on the pool and
8 will be written, it would seem a convenient move here
there is very strong black fingers again
just falling apart for the liking of nepal for
the horse is good
so you can play through d7 instead of well
yes took the white queen b7
that is, if you want to be at 7 then
albeit up to 5 of course, yes, apparently so
gotta black and yes it's not my mind
order, well, at least better than
nothing to that fights for the edge here by
to myself it is visible when 5 though
wait a second the first p5 routes positions
with b5
0 and not required to move the knight to 5 may
be possible to go say rook would be 8 on
all 4 pins 5 here because well, as it were
into the structure of blacks, frankly
looks so uncombed but at the same time
curly this game is pretty decent
like one very stuck diana one
until he takes part in the fight owns
you went there in response to it on the graphs would
number on 6 of lamp 404 slando 2 and which one
then here, too, all the same, a little white
ennobled velor want to put op-2
of course the game is still pretty
pretty strong here
the knight on d5 is very cute and sharp
afraid and curious what fabi
up to 4 played absolutely at an instant pace
and in f.u.
but one of the two most obvious answers
by 4 as the first two inputs which is either
the check will be viewed in pdf i and
and again enife to think because
like it should be very and
very still ready for that position but
until I made a move, I think some
gave they kept going 4 to 4 to 5
5 already went itself loops 4 all the same
they were going to 4 that is exactly
here it is here on this finger
oriented by the way pawn with check everything
we didn't want 8 came somehow
bent and 8 or 7 rather all eight
probably out of these two to overcome somewhere
our 5 problem is that i'm not a hero
not at all the one of these two moves then
rather first and 70 if it is not important to give
before the check version and such a game is worse but not
looks like you face took took and here
we suspect that first shower up before
76 because what else is it for us if the service
6 not so bad maybe possible
check in 6 but there we say it is necessary
reckon with
with such graphics, yes, that's elephant c5
there are some in some version yes but
jump out on c5 here on can bring a
for something in exchange it is necessary to count the move
dc on carraju word 2
some 5se old vs income
autostyle david zone in 4 probably still
stronger pommel plugged 2 hanging in
end damn well and again actually too
leads to certain problems.
for blacks because there is no more convenient
trade get it or not means bad
went elephant not our hearts 7-7 after all
much more natural than anything else
but wait you don't go d5 so u
blacks should be a full clearing so
needed to find continue one adept
although here on setting up 6 but does not have time and
then the height would then be 75
but up to 5 is very critical, but still
move firmly 7 move was clear with a margin
most naturally there is a move of the rook and
one creating not a threat furby 36 of course
threat again because there at the end
after gta 5 will hang as if from it
rather all Orthodox as if in 60
it seems 6 we needed anyway
it just seems to happen a lot
because we went from the fields and strongly again
ready 1 to 5 hung walking up cheats
therefore, in general, even what move is not visible
then do well, except for the company, take on bo 7
video at least if here before 5 then
after eating cult 5 to 5 5 water to 5
let's say festa 6 appears here and so on
Feels like white close defeat just
broke through ravaged issued inside the bowl
livestock measured then that is well finger
most dangerous anyway
somehow beat saved sent on
four goals deed friday
but it is clear that this is not what was dreamed of
good life very responsible
because there options top can me
won't work but I don't see how easy it is
I can't seem to catch him
it is very important of course that there is at least
say or burn otherwise it was a finger
would be really scary for the tags and
I guess that's what I suspect too
ends with some draw there after
first again abec'i say aliyev was axis
I think that with a high probability scientists
there is no problem here
or say officially in this law
smash too we go for now let's say c 76
and on horseback from wine just volume you
sent him 8 help and citrine to me here
this finger really like why because
that it seems that the structure is in ruins
so powerful if necessary 5th comes
or for 4 demolition batteries they do
it is not clear how it is displayed up to 4 to 5 goes
the fact is very or me it's unexpected
decision because I don't see either we are there
could have miscalculated
a simple option up to 5 5 this well, so on
Feels like it's white already absolutely anyone
asking for nothing already
seriously do not hope not for such an advantage
souls where you can not beat the queen hanging
than 76 no faith honda 5 to 5
you can’t beat 66, 50 packets will go
fest 6 most natural move not
the only but obviously the most erased
suggestive
and here again, if we allow
salon 76 but it seems to me just salvation
already and will not be, therefore, it is permissible to get along and
4 times don't own up to 4
well, here, too, well, let's say from such a move
for example, according to the feeling whites are forced
go to some like this well and here 6 5
cm to 4 m fight for a draw shoulder what yes
it looks like we are waiting for the blitz here I am
I’ll say a little in advance, well, how is it already
a good script should be considered
when will fabian give me the best
believes that the camp is still not good here
c-615 you can yes but you can but
effective doubly take away here I can
really why am I not taking the aspect
highway protection
here for example take for example there is this
the bishop will play for example there is such a move
hasn't given up any of his pawns yet
greedy greedy and asked how we are
actually exchanged, yes, and
the move went well yes 0 no probably a draw
added beat came here baby one
yes yes here probably what would be there
transfer let's play let's play it of course
when increasing there went a94 attacked b2
there is found 2 went c3d such an example
it is clear that the water has already gone up to the 4th
rook place 5 so black can
get the previous portion that we
discussed painless go sun
five fingers your post is unpleasant
objectively sun 5 we must see us
another move you're not up to bc 94 there are villains
4 I don't believe in him at all
seems to have created took the bishop g4 well, yes, although
would have appeared in the night bytes of times possible
achieve 405 king same 2 but here went
I think there is at least a rook and 8
some sit down to come on almost new
I know who is stronger
wears zones in 4 on if you are completely dumb
a6 c5 on 404
if white could such a cycle of type 2 by
4 they would do anything but not how
ordinary or shadows can and therefore should
walk on on the water until 1 water can be
they jump off
maybe not let's say here I am
fixed it on b2 with the next move
wish 8
black porridge pawns are all on the fields char
floor elephant therefore because
more cultured a little somewhere could play there
be a rook db-1 it's certainly there water
many major challenges reward given to u
villains one unexpectedly might be on
anyway for now
and even in if thinks because besides
that he still has the opportunity thought
you have the opportunity here
probably white heisman f4 hangs on c4 and
it is not very clear which one protects
Yes, probably
then it would be such a draw before
what else can be offered to black here
there's some fierce move in 6 on there
such a feeling that it should not
no success lead therefore please
elephant c5 you must sing the most tear
natural here of course actually
so we talked about it with
from the very beginning
well, whites will have to have some kind of
very pleasant even moreover keep again
let's repeat
for 65 we discussed but besides this there is
trying to play for activity let's say 18
I thought elephant c4 queens 3 but or korolev
one for hanging on for two actually
joy is in appearance
may be king h3 pretend to be there
no one answer for whom we went
but in general 5 5 6 5 today we
still up work in progress on
rebound even before white has to work out
here its a draw i.e. we here you in
second party lookin in some 2
catalan row new first was
so classic it's catalan in
which so it was according to the samples and
failed to start a fight in business
the second is white with one how to tie them
got out fighting but looks like his
leisure does not seem to this at all
glad so yes so it was
a little hasty announcement about the fact that
blitz will certainly take place for this
fabi will need to be even neater from
why do you need to work here yes so
offhand offhand not only to yet
just like the owner
while he is still thinking in this position
because we repeat youth
quality makes in general of course
it's not okay, it can't be good either
go up two or king g2 start goods
two
I know it shouldn't be like this
here the owner of 2 and 3 has a move, as it were
which removes the question no owned 12
of course not at all, well, it's some kind of again
here again rook 4 maybe like this
you know there 55 well, it feels like we are
We try our best to make it as difficult as possible.
to your own making you're nothing
need it won't work at all
will rise 4 later as no
politically wrong column 2
bark 2 and here is the central one
moment such will go in if you hold
pawns c or try them for some
reset temporary initiative
the other seems pretty to me
attractive don't know something
stronger nose again its not the most
naturally, and there this position is bishop c4
slando 4 and rook on some square
first row so wait no pebbles
walking elephant and in 4 seconds two suns 3
still without well on one side before with
the other side
owns 20 f30 h3 can be without
paddles but all these no man's trend even
no king on bayonets to become not optimal
on the other side there are so many
dad's weakness to be too lazy everything will wrap up
yes that we probably shouldn't much
here to suffer a lot
may be
[music]
thinks thinks fabi no ours a little
the logic of events is incomprehensible, that is, the grain
from blitz shaft debut after this number
so no well maybe they didn't expect
strain that if you take it seriously
this idea has it that is 1000 what it is
not some kind of bluff impala
semi-bluff idea and that's on the go
made in if white has this
here is the waste which they have unfortunate here
good move i think we're being taxed in
Chat Moisture And Two At Once By Themselves
and now just yes in order to slando
4 1 also 4 have move d4 yes this is it
cute geometric threat idea and
again say but also darling and 8 would also be 2
4 attacking the elephant stopped
family tree 2 is very cute
look responded to be this here one
of these moves which as soon as its
discovers that he is in position
immediately seems quite obvious and
very strong the main thing I know you
skipped to the main task of finding him
trying to get around someone recently lost
party in black too man in the finger
which it seemed to me absolutely
safe raised exactly hit one a
two and suddenly it turned out that this
the course of absolutely everything connects the board
all the figures that seemed to me
subject to movable disconnected
and and objects for the counter game itself
in fact, everyone played together at once, but I
I have problems with my
directly here in my first single
in the synthesis cup 16 denver me
beat to a high degree with rook 2
maybe from that time here still
Yes, once again they ask for a set
chess has any house name
already answers this question
called with freesync or yes it is
sunhill kit would try to translate
i.e. made specifically for it.
these tournaments and actually
made by house of stone
thinks while fabiana has time
still more because he is pretty
made a big start in the opening because
first thought in the seventeenth year in
this party for good all inclusive
4 inclusive White made all the moves
immediately therefore here offer a rook
3 but it seems to me less successful
2 really well actually white
white porridge has a fairly large supply and
tell me on slando 4 I'm thinking maybe
you can make a draw even just go
elephant guitarist basement one yak-3 me
to be honest, I was a little embarrassed by the course of the servant
one fall off max stand until it is impossible
owns 2 i kinda want we really
very stupid be must be 4
I'm not sure what to say so much
went in response owns 3 let's say before us
lamp 4 went to the salon e3 and started on it
how to attack it as if 4 not
look its like to went to 4
keep there much more involved
accepts
what's happening on the board
but an important decision because there are many moves
at least they look playable
eat from london for good not
disproved in the analysis care looks
quite meaningful and serves 4 rather
only if White then defends
optimally definitely should not lose here
rook vladom and rook also not very good
I like it, yes, I personally like the entrance very much
I like it I'm always very happy
geometric motifs on the board should
let's wait for the decision
it’s not clear yes, that is, such a pause
starting to think about not better for whites purely
theoretically after rook 2
Well, I think not, because even if
let's say the pawn c5 can be taken away here
some position according to the figure, let's say
slando 424 went to this position 18 what
let's say hell 826 though here
6 years before though two looks very
decently, that is, I think that's how it is
the same case when
burrow's move just to find it must go in
list of moves you are in this position
dealt with further you already with
most likely you will because
he seems very very often behind can
be stock 4 by 4 owns 5 bye
protecting the owner of two numbers you convene
as long as you can elephants 4 go still attack on
this black mush is bandaged after
how did they put the figures like that
well bandaged hand and foot
on the radio one and two Fabians of course not
Wasted time thinking about this
position, the move is made, but again, how do we
seems to be the strongest position before there
an offer of 1000 then bring the cat to 6
which would certainly be very good
idea but its most likely on the move a
pioneers will answer a6 hard to imagine
a situation in which black will be
forbidden to go again a6
in this case, we rather weakened our
club than improved because we would have her
it’s better to keep on the margins of your
the bishop they are on nothing on the whites and
did not start fields ruslanovich
elephant i'm one conditional one complete
did you try to add valuable no but in
this how to shoot the rush now
so far I have corrected and 8 can be like
then like this try to scrap the beats 5 well
there go on the channel she 2 fields and we
ready to cut off a little rook rook on
advance friendly and on occasion tee
pawn axes starting when extremely
unclear battle then specifics are important
la diva 2 as if from pawn support
oman cut up the number of wearable good on
lee sail income rooks 88 he so people
do not play chess rook and 80 to
give one step and send the second rook
on 8 and brother, even though black can have it
that's all right because
the strongest in this position to be honest
if yes but but just make it by hand
impossible because everything is inside
will rebel against
everything will rise up against such
all in all
time for if you think about what
happens because I suspect that 12
he did not see from afar now he needs
somehow
adjust to this new situation.
time lights of course scientists have it on
for at least one major pause in
this position because
11 minutes of the finger most likely requires
one such serious dive into
fabi its serious dive only
what demonstrated here rook 2 found
assessed as it seems to us right and
now is the time for
for you to understand what why to choose
some constellations here even if we
want here if we want and though draw
if we want to receive like a finger success
end of life should not waste time on
dresses up to 80 immediately paid 6 i.e.
show again
much clear would be 4 for this
shop 9 just went completely sushi
I didn't attack anything here, I just want
as early as possible to secure oneself a pawn
it is on white that they are on a black field and on
pc go let's say santiaga is not like that
looked narrowly we did not have time provides
aslan on the right diagonal because
that under the link becomes impossible than
immediately lose therefore slates 7 to
sun 7 well, we continue after him in that
or otherwise chase on and
vladimir 16 villains 6 to 166 drank beat
And
well here in general try somewhere
well, the truth is here, as if there will be 5
stand steadily that is when she we
putting up to 8 of the planets
we can anal dressed 4 night fell and well
yeah, that's how they hold up
example, but they are already so responsible
decisions and
such a sharp restructuring from an extra pawn
and the obvious struggle for victory to
on foot, you must immediately give more
you need to have a little
carefully make a series of moves so as not to
find yourself in the worst endgame it happens to be
hard to change plates
change head record yes so that's it
if he thinks what else he has
opportunities, but in general, how would
The problem is that it's not very clear what
do your job by 4 i.e. can
you can only decide for yourself what
such a drawer
blondes should all but if you look
honest well he can draw but go
you need less on it come on very strong
how to say emotional health elephant
I'm the only one in which while he is still there
as if f2 is still in this date yes no
No
we will also return the rook to the war johnny1 i
wanted my own 3 2 3 us lamp 4 this is this
doesn't, that's probably taken
although how is it different well you can
you can try to ride somehow
hold this rook on volodya b.v.
but the logs would 8 owns all the water and
you've always been nothing so probably a draw
because with such a massive but
make faces dinner run but don't have to bit
all
having mastered sergeev staff one sample
biologists will passively be it
was a good decision in terms of
attempts to make forced yet but
after the elephant already went to 4 respect again
thinks here in general can be imagined
imagine scenarios which evenings can
become like the biggest change ever
because I told him poison for a long time and
confidently talked about the fact that black
a decent margin sent debut 5
version 6
even in such fingers you can
turns gape beautiful geometry
you can’t even name a tactic or beautiful
geometry is like this and now in general
talk about black being better
probably won't hear from us again
really interesting c7 descent to ponder
maybe even an elephant and at 4 maybe we can
buy paradigm dark yes it's true
I was wondering if it makes sense to hunt
let's say camps 5 in that position on
We're well done a 20 man I
leaked 4 walked
but there is a move and get along 2 also by the way but
then with 2 live 8 try something like this
and my size is not one pair, but the whole
school is like 4 here so I don't know
how embarrassing this white is right away
Odessa number 4 there is a move that you see 7
in the solution test, I already have it c6
there is any could data sheet bc
over one immediately draw on any take and
I go well there or took took to get dressed 2
and go wrong 2 won back White's c6-pawn
maybe even half a penny
it’s more pleasant to understand what is most likely
black there is some kind of finger never
not lost or else I can go bye
Well done a two pose a threat to the pc from
which protection by sight
comfortable, no, but there is, for example, some
here played 18 b l d d 5 white 1 to 6
teach now all the rooks are good
fields, too, probably stuck to the pawns here
base 50 of as equals to
12 well, I think yes, the unity of chance
control the cargo owner too 22
if one pair is removed, then maybe
whites can somehow attack cancer if
play lodent maybe yes in if walks
camp at you and me here we expect that
will follow bc because we are here by
four by five but it hurts how to say
into conceptual
need a little more light figures
to pour organic there still look
owner let's get the most sko little money
not the cylinder head and she is afraid of course because
there say blacks on but you could again
for example think finally hsbc is going well
8 myself before trying 6 even though actually
such fingers are convenient and she showed at
we had a version about an elephant and v4 pro here
here he will probably raise the rook as it grew
grandfathers 5 and here we just yawned
water there water here we really are here
villains up to 8 and on the elephant up to 6 unexpectedly
passes kind of like a sleep beat 5 and
generally 35 cents to 15 here and we
unexpectedly do not have time to beat the elephant
because the rook is looking for what rumors draw
Yes, it’s a finger, of course, sometimes he took the checks
us not on this finger no better and no worse
killed
until raw on elephants 4 that is you
is also trying to go if he has
something stronger can start owns 2
on then the word can when not get on
45 it seems ruslan 4 of course you have to walk
firewood actually happens to the game need g
well, you need to find some water up to 5
because and once again what we had there
water until 21 in room 18 and now I can't
come up with here as as for minus
move this whole structure, yes, because
that our londa 6 got into the habit 2 somehow
years for the kingdom there is a move too black
back 5 and we have no tactics
no, you can turn on santiago uncle semyon
doesn't change anything
also on the bishop up to 6 all the same tactical
blow solves all problems yet
5 minutes shortened to when in
time on i this party 800 same time
scientists are a bit up to actually but
most likely after the water to 5 game he has
going to be pretty simple and pizza's steel
pawn on the conscience he correctly count
these options and will understand care slando 6
no need to be afraid then ale's dresses 8 for now
makes a move in if it's a little narrower
other positions
instead of dragging on Ladino 2 and likeness
beats 50 white year beat in such
natural order and no double
hitting 2 rows will not be possible to carry out
up to 2 large view with cameras bring up to 2
tons of raw materials to get better 5 then black
just win back the elephant but understandable
it's like every now and then that white first
they need to hit 8 and only then jupiter 5
so you can call tel 12 with a word apparently
will be forced to go to f6 and rejoices
from there yes and we can go to 16 true
again even in this position sent
dress up 8 if you stood on the old boat
we get then maybe it would be
we would have some serious chance of
advantages and so I don’t see what yet
white can achieve so wait
which water up to 2 like in 6 up but
some kind of magic
can't see authors code 6 correctly
absolutely
although that white water is up to 6, well, just volume
took 81 water and at least 4 moves we only
elephant before 6 even first
them then they probably have time to colin
run up to 6 and while they create such
holland would 40 to 70 get along to 7 so on
actually you can gradually again up to
play to the fingers that should be
then your passwords don't participate until 12
like a part we actually see however
rights that need to be preserved to master
until 6 you have to walk here but again here I am
I can't find any progress so far
White can achieve in this position
korolev 3 let's say yes, but even if
let's say for now the king and all
gave 14 it's just the dimensions of the rogue handed out
I was thinking about this plan too.
try to change one but not very much
it is clear what we are trying to achieve even if
black people don't try it
hinder there took took went to
roles 8 then went elephants 7 and I'm all here
we have some activity
own up to 6 already played but keep whether
be that you if some well yes we have 6
you can't give them away, hating them too
I don’t see how losing owned up to 6 well
just impossible don't seem to hand
force to make such a move because
grandfather 6cd she has 8 even have them before
will have to go right on 8 on
next move, well, as if comparing this
it seems to me that this position should be brought up to 88
actually already played the choice is pretty
obvious there's a little so that's the pressure
someone is some some
pressure is maintained until
so wait i can't have any baguette with
the way we walk
thought that not re7 absolutely fair u
natasha, again, black immediately has time
we don't even have time to cling to c5 pawns
water usually either 700 seems to have achieved
absolute maximum for belov but all
equals the feeling that she was breaking the foundation that
from 4 to 4 and very important again
Let's repeat that's why black is so
early and went for heart 6 because if
you what no pays off succeeded white
fix a pawn on c75 like this
position is already on good bid very
serious
party and what we are seeing now on
the screen here is drafted to be kept in
Cup
it's not even very clear, actually
maybe you can go like this
not the usual good places and go well and
enjoy 5 5 like f8 radio 7
817 zones look for what we have achieved at least
some kind of progress balance is rather
just probably decide progress yes, well, for now
themselves just walks h2h 4-x looks like this
a bit empty so blacks get
another rush for some course
constructive package 7 h5 goes to if
again, it's logical.
his desire to prevent h5
fix all those pawns on
on the fields of the color of the color of the whole elephant
scientifically it is absolutely correct but here
reappears this micro and action
either 4 which even micro edison same 5
here they can not beat just winning
everyone yes and still I want everything
attach somewhere in this position to the water
up to 40 well majors cynically beat couples 4
beat on the chain
it is then that it remains, of course, extremely
they carried very little, if at all, the state
white can keep on she insist
to the fact that they continued to dive gur and but
continue to put pressure on the chair they say
such situations
so it will most likely last
hold in if we start to watch
those same micro sets of two parties but not
we will get ahead of ourselves a lot
some advantage on the clock all the same
8 points to four if he succeeds
somehow continue the party pave it
question and put or black it can
seem important
until they understand that even 4 h5 is possible
she thought she thought 4 actually
we have already spoken in this position
started smoking about something that is not very clear
what, in principle, to make a move from the point
of achieving at least something f4 is
understandable and so instinctive
solution improved a little paid in
space plus there say after a
tree check king in 3 no one on h2
black could beat such
this is logical h4 and h5 but here is the question
what to do he can't even drops in
our version of the king of austria before
rim gotta try owns 4 someone
one you probably is still
remains the most logical
way to keep fighting here
tanned rubbed 2 rave went fabiana
yes but then again and in if not obliged to go
to the role in 70 this message is 5 i constantly
I think in whose favor such an exchange is not yet
so I couldn't decide for myself
rated with possession 1 which in if
does activating while dozing rook
on and 8 tires if you think about it, then up to
passively login from 85 black so
everything is compact
full time steady some me
so I would like to try 5 there
to exchange elephants what I understand
Surely there is logic in this, but
specifically there are problems with
implementation of all these plans and again
forge see black just won't
beat not even porridge everyone needs to go
namely water and 4 because if we say
rook one then maybe you can try
play to win such a position though
certainly
practice suggests that white
stop ladies red decides you need
rarely drive out we controlled pricks
7 before us, the machine ran rarely but aptly
yes, all these general arguments about what
where black controls and where they can
stumble upon that by rush c
queens pass and then king and 6 yes she
does not go through the basket seems to be lost
a pawn because I sent this fingers
18 and may not threaten anything but protection
pawn f7 snarls and that didn't fight the gun on
water was given to his own camp 4
already at the pub early and went
I think it's easy to kill now
risky because they will show what
Eugene said that the inclusion of h4 and h5
gives White a very dangerous plan pinned in
56 such
own and okay bishop e7 and seriously
I thought about why the king is king again
of something they don't
i king e5 dump also does not pass by
6 here's the water and 8 step kings can go
the ship will be beaten by the king a706
taken really serious risks
probably need to go somewhere with a rook
maybe giving check first makes sense
from such considerations of neatness again
and on the move by the king most likely down here
now do i'm alone and maybe
taxes and 6 general blacks may include
some kind of circuit game mode tell u
I'm also quite a lot of chances to sell
such shah
not party b3 my dinner creed because
if the rook would two check the king to 3 then
such a feeling we will drive the muscle with mice
king to redness where he wants
give us both dresses 3 king and 4 fret
four kings in 5 so very much from there
will give white black gave a couple
three checks and the magician will give white
so this is how he played dahab owns 4
first 10 already played
question question how to castle again
I repeat I will be very surprised if if
you blindly beats because in fact
this is not entirely true because
Slavic is a very specific attempt
do the mission immediately if there is no move
king e5 I'm not sure that he is everything
need to somehow soberly evaluate indigo
Well, here's the water to 7 the sun to tenge 5 is
quite empty maybe even itar tass
you want them in space if you enter
on f8 then this position is still simple
right away
walks in with when and we walked here pro
not in this one almost immediately I'm 41 and in this
after we went rook 6
I'm still holding on
the opinion that without filed her 6 white is real
can't fight here for serious
overweight because it is not very clear what
they want services from life 5 possible
try to check no maybe but here
those same elephants 5 say but the truth is we
gave away an important enough bone yes
so far so far pick up pick up our 5
so that there were no axis powers
and the advantages of controlling all one
prices until the possibility of the same
ideas wins on the floor took away the field would be 8
high degree
also because he would have taken the field 8 would have given dead
3 check i trisha king should most likely
pump knives drainage 3d
well
in principle, as long as we control polyube 8
maybe the king is almost not very
it is clear where he is the page in response to
the rest of the shahid should still be
put on a cell on which it is not
can attack hair like rook three
probably for sure
exact pillow stroke to this elephant i 5
we own axes yes of course drive away
drive the king away from the good fields in
the center is always useful and so is it
need to be reminded that there is a party
broken and
the fact that 5 against two we have on the clock is
can be very, very important well
let's say in this position it is necessary to count the move
dresses 7 first
because let's say on the water up to 8 whites
overlap another vertical and
organize some kind of meaningful circuit
game black will highly not have to
make it awkward moves. 7 actually
in fact, here we are in the water until 7, apparently very
strong was the decision he left on the water
and 6 but these are the ideas I like
more precisely because we continue
play full limit 18 hobby
the elephant starts to get off before 6 but also in general
it looks pretty logical
again, here is the maximum guarantee
you will not return anywhere not such tactics all
protected everything protected the owner 8
just cut it out, yes, but so far, nothing
we want to objectively next
move I think that white can be bishop e7
he wants to create some kind of pseudo
own 8 always a soldier 7 will bunch
along the line
Well, it's just not easy to make a move.
the machine made one constructive move
who came up with such a put b3 with that
to get better and go fret b4
novatek these on occasion even the king and in 3
may be heaven thoughts king h7
came out went that the boat is cut off 7
conceived interesting
therefore, in appearance it is very risky collecting
her watched he's about to go the elephant of the garden
stage elephant and 5 that's favorite favorite
evgeny though elephants 5 looks here
this saved wins according to my feelings
while recently owning 8 cm and more
affixed heart we still framed
king h7 under all these shohin camp 8
there is, well, as if nothing is found
cleverer
that is, the move is like a 4 step here which
by the way, most likely very strong because
that again we are taking the 4th camp
took away c and let's go sell them too but
besides this, there is also a move rook wife
hold 5 hold five and here is also true
here it is hard that arise back
asian places took their sizes and took
66 shorter than 725 steel rear most likely
but where got excited 'bout wins but
porridge options will have to be considered very and
very neat than it probably is
possession 3 step from 2 and 2 hours two to
king ht ht this is especially considering
position in if on the clock is not so terrible
like it because
offered by when you have problems with
temple here please do more do it
one more
while we, for the time being, will strengthen the position of our
rook 2 play if changed
something in terms of these in spiers
offhand, I do not immediately see the conditions of the villains
8 I keep trying every turn
count with us 5 proficient 8 on the subject
did it become more white here
I don’t see any advantages than before
how white can try to strengthen his
here you can go here rides 3 a
in fact, this is probably a rook 2 and
directional appears unexpectedly
repeat much counterplay associated with
41 wait a minute let no then
normally went 14 Odessans can the sun
wag me to the fact that i gave her four
such a strange attempt and cutting on
victory when she invades
repetitions of moves on the same
cell so once again let's discuss everything
still this stud elephant is not 5 but for him
hope 7 king 6 still would like
elephants save on the board beaten beaten
dress a4 rook
where 6 owners 4 get along 6
well, nevertheless, but 6 well, let's go bye slando
6 barbel if the elephant went to 6
apparently words are no longer the king's judge
you need samba 4 or maybe you can
just like that, I thought that it would get better 6
it will be impossible and yes actually I also
read about tristan 576
sun 33 let's say went while dreams 4u 12
and already you can from a woman on leonardo you can
take on c6
yes it's not that even tougher up to 16 yet
tougher, yes, that is, maybe in fact
In fact, even here some is saved on
massive balance and now fabi is almost
nullified it on the screen you can see that
if the lagoon is your fault what on time is it
he doesn’t have 220, but we see that
less than two minutes just became
and could discern whether you don't want it
not 5 moves put 4 so wait
dabble in the clock just now
showed 4 minutes on 400 wrong
gave him back ten seconds of delay
relatively speaking for scrapping by 4 goes to if
and what us is under packed attacked 4
on the other hand it's a move from 1 wall
packed on the other side then chill me
in this sense, an aggressive game on however
for counterplay, that is, here it is necessary of course
what to do i swing water
fabi well, you see 4 pancakes 5
may have conceived or asked me to
rock on exiled 5 we start yeah but
black can hour try to go in
some gap but again here for this
we went
king h3 to water and eight pence
rejected such detachments the sun 3 returned and
here apparently now owns 5 can
try f5 you have to try to pronounce
gay track
this elephant again but again for scrapping
for 4 we will have to reckon with the move
service on the next then live and not
like this idea to walk the same 4-seater
us the same one many country house cover
pawn let's count the options
fadeev 5
what move I suspect that he sharpens you
communication I see another and now I want
suggest this fingers dig 0
up to 6p it seems like it’s necessary to beat, they took it and
beat our 5 then on e5 claim that
we have much more active rooks and therefore
we are better we have nothing of this already
happened because fabiana went
instead, rook 7 and 7 is such a game for now
the actor just threatens he doesn't 5 beat that
lody yes such a game on the total
domination
but until I force you probably need to
somehow try
I wanted to use
take advantage of the time bring out okay
8 point and while continues to remain
an embarrassing task to withdraw vodka 8
on the operational space on as if up to 65
committing a monster to own up to 8 i'm afraid
finds in since summer well at least on
Bishop e5 she gets counterplay
d2
at some point here is a question on elephant 5
you can walk and these are two divisions
until I can't refute
how monstrously scary directed too
sent 76 and they can't check
extinguished owning themselves eat this rook
am cancel me time threatens to one
move, and I’m already away from him and move 4
too incapable of being saved because of
yes, that is actually just as important
water resource up to 80 we can go for now
we can try to find behind the stove c
but somehow we can do it later
something not to give probably though that name
owner 6 she looks pretty
reasonable indeed caged position
because then rooks 8 and 2
starts in fact we can't already
throw and go becomes very very
spicy in Faberge is much less
time than owns 5 than he owns we
can go owns 5 on black probably
can even lean 3 just
let yourself get beat and go king on
some fields I don't know which one is correct
move 86
g8 and now white's king is free
doubtfire guzal continues to maneuver
while he's doing here's the rook family of six
again there for that transfer go
a little of them seems to me lost by whites
really disliked the idea became 10 phage
stayed there 20 seconds and six or seven
then somewhere around 7 is certainly an improvement
situations for Cherkasy 7 row covered here
this is what manifests itself in the song of vladi
weekday they are confident nervousness yes you can see
that both here are rapid chess yes you can see
that a little bit lost lost end
process control probably still everything
still case draw fritters 5 here to me
should be enough control says people 5
ports for sure it's time actually it's time
already
take the situation more seriously
control can go same 6 because 9
exactly low everything just perpetual check but
already 6 even 6 played pancakes 30 if he
should probably go back diagonally
already by what service 4 looks like
it's risky to say there that rook 805 is here in
in general, you can most likely be upset
that's why
elephant c4 ladies this is saving the elephant
diagonal is exactly what I was talking about
gotta keep it on
so 10 seconds 14 will go on serving one
walk the same 4 that's right that's right
because we keep the a4-pawn under
control and again we will be ready to beat
the king on the same 4 4 ​​row we do not
relaxed serving 7 it's time i think already
all the same somewhere in the mink because
sun 12 favorite service same 4 same
immediately 4 on 1 we prepared for this
for elephant 7, sleepwalking is possible here
4 new ones and which e3 dresses, too, at least
quite logically creating some
menace villains 7 then rests a lot on
I will say the question seems to be seven rooks symbol
db2 has loved something better man already
75 check and draw with skill
already 40 there is the same 4 yes, well, there are some
maybe a ball they will start
but judging by itself, the thought of parliament
should at least the camp semen ask not
gotta make myself ask
because otherwise do not depart possessions 2
scared that something grainy stance
although it seems to me that he had
pretty safe us here what exchange
rooks would be 4 probably already the order of accounting well
yes that black white too even stage 7
never in life so against they will lose
but probably black post caroji 8 king
h7 will be pretty calm there
looks like a draw
there was a feeling that until they were stranded in one
moment there was a decent chance of an advantage for
Fabian when I showed this
a strange combination with the exchange of bishops
took the screen to 4 in an intermediate move
walks-walks come out keep hinting at
went to play to win this position
what is this based on, I'm not very good yet
I understand that in the West for 4 natasha usa
probably Shado is fried 7 you can go to me
I wanted to say based on something like
and 7 you can’t walk, perhaps even white
the message to everyone does not lose there liskova
and across the sea before jumping on again, that is
longde 8 flower beds 6 can't seem to
just to the fortress yes, well, here here 177
it's time already because you don't like niches already
you can not give a mug of streams for 6 runs away
so I don't own copper 7 shahan king
g8 while the king is still standing knives 8 let's go
get along 7 fight 6 people in 4 what
such a blundered debut number not 5 me
let him out from afar apparently outlined
exactly what
that we don't have black fingers in this
have no particularly attacking options
yes, it's good that perfect blacks can
maybe even Dietrich's elephant through
we put the cover on the question of who has this better
bishops and gas ending with the king on h3
On she can't be, it's ivory better
be with white this fave generally takes
one elephant takes control of the situation before
On the 4th, not everyone decides that it's time already
yes, he could do it in that position
actually the very fingers that we and
we'll bring houses of torment to come dan so what
happened at this time with the clock at
I can't count my opponents
the king is everything but it's right that the king
need to be done as quickly as possible
own minutes pawn c nokia 6
probably the most correct thing here we are too
it is important to remind that [ __ ] you are always 4
saves white from some game
you already have 1 tako after all
blacks dacha third party sheikh zayed five
nenuko risked 5 monica grant from 1 and
6 neighbors jet pawn rush c to runs
models actually i got excited with not
jump, I completely forgot that
was not going to give up the pawn c6 and 4
against 13 king to 56 then
accumulates every not quite 4 not
quite 13 such that's offhand a draw on
harder we see something and just yes
yeah it's hard hard in from 7 to its end
not seen the course was not 55 owns again
there are no buildings that feel like a villain 8
no protection so but all yes yes
ended just like a victory
you definitely leading
and start to generally somewhere in what
positions so that it is not at all similar
on those
yes yes yes yes yes it's not clear yes hitch
such a phobia well not practical no he
naturally saw here rooks beta 4 but
I count for him I don’t count them photo 3
which will have to go anyway
sit down and then service 6 no like this
service two days means bill and
flirting up to 3 porridge good times stronger
for this reason it was strong and wins
you have a pancake 80 unity called up
cathedral from a distance from black fabiana agree
advances to the final tournament
london powers such a nervous victory in
second course site break spring itself
blurry nervous but actually this
nature must play such and such
definitely yes, and in the end
it turns out if we draw general conclusions
will be more general that fabius
played one good tournament out of 4 but
will allow the tournament was in the classics where
even sharing 1 place gave him a lot
points, then this outweighed heroism
heroism in if we say in paris or wine
which is, but if it also did not reach
played three good tournaments he played two
he had a good tournament
stock in front of the field after paris or blame
yes, just open into it not
not asked in any discipline
failed failed tournament yells and
blitz and then
in general yes tell me a good tour in
classics all he could achieve is
this tie-break against Fabian is
the project did not work out in the end
congratulations to fabiano caruana on the release
final not to london
I hope that having will manage it personally
we were promised to make Fabian in some
moment, let's see some moment
promised to bring let's see what happens
we don’t understand the account the account file so well and well
Yes, if only here in the game Yes, we are all all of this
seen with my own eyes giving both very
calmly made a draw in the Catalan
the first batch in the second batch in the end
quite already on the flags a little more precisely
been there and spiers and won a victory think
that black held a draw for quite a long time
still in this and spiers if not unsuccessful
decision too voted for kings by all
king is king to 5 so i judge
I can’t but the solution turned out to be extremely
suspicious and yes, well, in general, still
tell you what
on this today's broadcast we are but we
waiting for news on the subject by name nick
us fabiana tell examples understand
that they said it was quite a long time
now detained in an English studio
we are almost offered to take a break
but in any case, I think that it is possible for now
Well, maybe you can this morning, yes
let's say it again if
if someone suddenly turned on
just now passed two tournament site
lavessi rapid and blitz tour confidently
won hikaru nakamura 2nd place in the end
occupied your maxim for count this tournament
was also of great importance for the general
state of affairs on tour because
shakhriyar mamedyarov who 90 percent
rapido Iblis went nostril to nostril his
hikaru and they switched positions
leadership position there every tour they
changed first and second place but in
as a result, the cipher took 3 2 took the maximum
which gave him relatively calm
situation before the classics in terms of selection
to the final in London and that's until after that
classic tournaments were played here to us
finally shows this very ending
in london which we constantly mention
that's who hikaru nakamura got into it
35 points
thirty-three of which were recruited
I think up to the first three definitely yes
power to the classics completely failed
classics but still a leader
by points scored
if not for the victory of Carlson, then I
it seems that his
Aronian walked around, it seemed to me that probably
the paddock out stopped thirty-five and
five
but fundamentally but not so knock it out
series before it was impossible 2 second
the result of the Aronians before the truth and the third
maxim entered before count who did everything
nine draws in classic but this again
enough given that it is very tight
spent all three
tournament with shortened control and that's for
4th place we just watched
tie-break between American
chess players who you are his fabiana
wing as a result, we have absolutely stellar
line-up for the London final
nakamura karla and 2 probably the most
bright if you read again Carlson 2 on
the brightest chess players of recent years
levon aronian and maxim shmelya graph people
who played epic among themselves
semi-finals of the World Cup and more recently and
basically
I have been studying for a long time for a zone for
me in general yes I'm like an elephant
some kind of long memory some completely
no, it's all going to happen anyway
December, we hope that you will be able to
to tell this in December
follow the news what is it called
this seems to be a broadcast
broadcasting of this studio or completely finished
no, I think it's still a little break and
we are then promised fabi yes let's
let's turn around and come back here
after some time with the winner
today
[music]
it's easier for us flowers from the mess
Bolshunova finance.ua this shape
new and as a world live events lauren
and plays the androgen of his disc start
line
yuri on the k from one consist i and tons or
sex and five
no return here cameras withers
Informative Facts But Have Lawrence Writing
not have his works
one piece kill match match on fans hour
sheathe lopez on the pedal wammy does one
that's my
jumping he will go with the audio guide with me
this here is loves bien and
in both self skills and trending
my stab bummer hoxton
downhill noisy thoughts gas our series
letters you are a [ __ ]
[music]
we break free and mrs barclay went down
by brush site even
ball
[music]
revealed to use under kids play and yours
slide elvish
he is so tons for [ __ ] pants loverboy
[music]
he was his
yuri
Captain Alexander Ivanov Alexander
shiseido frequency classic servers
with through my live backup channel and throw it out
store for me i am sometimes
purpose as well as for me pool elegance
handbag hour thank you so much
million play half currency along dynasty street and
she has him still in mantua containing with
indesign hex file
the most said which will remain
bolt on on on on on on on on on on on on
on on on on words.
[music]
Nika
andgave
[music]
you
at
[music]
and hello again we are here now
picture let's talk with the winner
today's tiebreak fabian [ __ ] with
hardly managed to drag him into the studio, he
it’s clear that you’re tired, well, you’re satisfied
so we agreed that
we will not analyze the parties in detail which
fact and synod tui nga index
santo domingo indostan you problem
released in black
import but he's here I'm with him and I'm like this
and could not collect positive he became I killed
behind their masks and blitz mite and for
fare interns and get up to for just
type protected warm tweezers for her
old key combination like a new new
summer is written reefs on it we have a type
why woke up to a breakthrough at the apparatus and
cubic ansys extremism, parts on
emotions the whole continent will understand the truth
it seems you reach the policy
comfortable less dancing
I asked with my ears since we are in common
agreed with him outside the studio
we won't move by move
disassemble these parties basically of course
it makes sense to say only the second
party since at 1 but talk that
he recently saw that the versions
8 walked basenji and
and they did the same in the park by correspondence
which is now of course the source
a lot of interesting theoretical novelties and
there will be a complete draw, therefore
it's good that today we managed to show something
and as for the second before in general says
it was such a freestyle because but
fighter had a look at the
past the first circle 6 knights and 5 say and
there he knew that there is a photo 6 which we
also discussed off the air and also
achieved, too, not the best some sharp
an unclear position arises and the knight c6 in
in general, it was a surprise to him
I say well, you continued to play
immediately at Brad's after think
didn't want to at all, therefore, as it were
walked fast then had energy
bending .
I was taking me out you see dancing
steam at on on on on on on on on on
on on on on facts about being searched with onions and
media jossom from them killing avatars referee
no need for critics especially moment 800 he
could play fruit five inter in cafe i it
pro where is the picture in the cemetery 10
bucks worth a haircut full active on ya
lookin' at six
this is not a slingshot renault ais
papyrus players
i'm looking for pi yao ming disappeared from us under 700mb
roof stop and but I say what I asked
fabi as he appreciated with Dasha since
we would tell you that killed worse and
fabel actually also confirmed that
fall did not like at all until he
did not find the entrance rook 2
which we were given to chats as soon as
he found in gladio 2 obviously immediately
becomes what exactly it needs to be done
crockery is over there thought to do some
to ask such a draw for a draw roughly speaking
with a move of 4 or elephants 4 cm, it is for four
up to 1 year there she is so all obscure
after rook 2 black should look for
nothing, I tried to ask him there and
in one particular position but again
without a board, here in the version that we already
not shown after 6 5 6 b l d 5 but
the fans had some ideas that we
yet again
don't show and and dogs like myself so bad
thing problems high on x-ray
a menu file at all the manual
nissan and waving at the game pair
beautiful
you attacked the asset analysis believe
rings with live because it is dedicated
it may turn out to be my edge of the file, here it is
me a huge tank like terminator me
well, then when to stabilize
here is this structure rush mi5s 6th
run around like book hall what i have
completely won because it succeeded
completely cut off completely from the game by
98 but didn't you find a way
win some pawn and in the end
found out how to begin already became completely
little time and decided to play as much as possible
reliable, but at the same time save at least
some hint of life in a position to
did not work out immediately and a draw
but I have had games several times
chances of misfortune may be something
eat on release the rook there on it
strong 2 and in such a situation when there
little time on the clock is nicer black
play so I would try to keep under
control
and and after the exchange of water and again but I
was absolutely sure
on the air that should be nothing accurate
moves but during this time managed a little
look at the computer itself
do not give a draw and actually
in if not feelings and not made in the party
or close didn't even make the alphabet too
says that he thought that probably how
then held on by a pawn very dangerous and not
held out
ok naf naf of this game can dance
and wanted to make me feel this way data
safe for 13
looks
I asked his being now it's clear
that it is good to qualify for final but not for
all thoughts on the first of his two tournaments
London he gets that course match on
world championship is occupied by absolutely everyone
its time but still very nice
qualify for tournament finals often
because after the monstrous first two
tournaments lie down Lena it was in general
an extremely unlikely event
what he takes and in particular he
says while watching
ended the score yesterday
suddenly felt what was important to him
now, if before that he became strongly on this
he didn’t think the topic very much
and in particular the party has here
cardboard cupid somehow prompted again
a strong desire to get out
waves therefore very pleased that
what it turned out 5 balls can
pumpkins and site so well
hong kong germans feet winning are
fine well in the heart
well, and if we are still on the air, then here it is
your screen
next event to take place
st louis
from 11 to 14 September will be held
I hope that very interesting matches
puffy width u pair you see on yours
screens garry kimovich kasparov will return
going to chess for four days or
topper in the woods anish giri
american champion 7 seconds white vs
maxim entered la grav levon aronian other
lineira dominguez and it will be possible
mock your commentator
who will chew on the figure on the figure
for the game against Ikar Nakamura in fact
business to talk about what can pass
some interesting tournament in which
there is katar svidler one of the roles before
we will try, I'm sure that you and
people love the role of a commentator very much, but also
I still have great pleasure
I'll play the question what's the matter
How easy will it be and how
principle
the feeling that I understand that
going on the board you contribute well
let's see, let's see on the most will not start
we don’t recognize Peter for several years now
sings this sad song about what is
leaving chess and so on and so forth
sometimes, well, I bait her
I arrived in private conversations I'm sorry
previously submitted to the public but
I just want to point out that sometimes
it drives me to check
just in case, I find the world ranking
its there somewhere in the second ten and
calm down in general while no one is going anywhere
doesn't go away then goes nowhere again
now thank you all
for watching us
we hope that at least periodically
says something meaningful about this ether
for me too, I talked about it by
the end of the first 5 I will say again for
it is my great pleasure to work
work as a wife and
continues to be unlucky for partners in the booth
we hope again that in December we
they seem to promise that in December in the same
in the same composition yes let's do it again
let's see we are the last one left
graphic here is one last
graphic image
what are we blonde but london in
London will host the final tournament
grandola him russia capital you
nutrition yes well it's ok dacha
would and no
4 participants we already called it gave
At first, Amur Aronian Maxim's Bureau went to
Count Fabiano Caruana
I will be virgin two semi-finals and then the match
for third place which I did not know
initially turns out to be a match for the third
place and the final match which will be
exactly like the World Cup
2 to the classics, most likely given that
in total we have seven days for all this
exercise 2 in classic and beyond
some format rapido needle as
tiebreak if 11 prizes 120 80 60 and 40
thousand US dollars and
naturally on the eve of the title of the winner
literature ok you know that's interesting
reminded I spied on the interview
Fabiana in the English studio and reminded
What did he win last year?
tiebreak in london
yes u fabian and u-uy she is not a brawler that me
overall it needs to get better
long standing situation become break in
features with those breaks pierced and
faster because again to finish
pour over there was always a period when Fabian
often cited as an example
super strong chess player in the class
which is not a very decent minute would
significantly weaker than its level in
the classics are played by a rabbi
it gets harder and harder it seems to me
with probably more and more strained
to justify this approach and
feature look good he has it
it turns out that situations when one on
alone and on horseback
something your content something 20 this
hold on Magnus then it won't be very
and very no experience makes the match up
additionally interesting yes because
this is such a good school for
potential tie-break flama
but thanks again to everyone
watched we hope you will come back with us
arching if in this studio in london
watch this very final bullet
for four she is today and generally on
August broadcast ends broadcasting
ends august ends from
using our cannot
look and become and until I'm done
say happy birthday to my chief
in the life of coach Andrey Mikhalkin
who is 70 today, I could not resist him
called grid but also publicly still
once I say that I am very, very
thankful
[music]